WE ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEMS OF THE BORDER, WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE PROBLEMS THAT
CAUSE PEOPLE TO FLEE TO THE
BORDER.
>> Dana: VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
FACING PRESSURE FROM SNAPPING
BACK.
LET’S BRING IN A CHAIR,
RONNA McDANIEL.
ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10, WITH TEN
BEING THE ABSOLUTE WORST, HOW
THEY GET A STRATEGIC BLUNDER
HASN’T BEEN FOR VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS TO HAVE NOT GONE TO THE
BORDER IMMEDIATELY?
>> I THINK IT’S 11.
WE ARE KNOWN TO BE AT A CRISIS
POINT.
THIS IS DIRECTLY BECAUSE OF THE
BIDEN HERE IS POLICY.
SHE HAS BEEN IN CHARGE OF IT AND
IS REFUSING TO EVEN ASK SIMPLE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK SHE
SHOULD EXPECT.
WHY HAVEN’T YOU GONE TO THE
BORDER?
IT HAS BEEN 79 DAYS.
YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF THIS
CRISIS, AND YOU ARE MISSING IN
ACTION.
>> Dana: I WANTED TO ASK YOU
MORE ABOUT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY SHE IS A BIT OF A
LIGHTNING ROD.
SHE IS PROBABLY GOING TO GET
ATTACKED BY REPUBLICANS.
SO BE IT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE A REPORT
ON THE ELECTION IN 2020.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID
ABOUT MINORITIES AND VOTING.
VOTERS OF COLOR ARE PERSUASION
VOTERS WHO NEED TO BE CONVINCED.
REPUBLICAN ATTENDS TO BRANCH
DEMOCRATS AS RADICALS WORKS.
COVID-19 AFFECTED EVERYTHING IN
OUR HOPES FOR 202020 WERE JUST
TOO HIGH.
WHAT HAPPENED YOUR EFFORTS TO
TRY TO CAPTURE SOME MORE OF THAT
MINORITY VOTE?
>> THAT HAS BEEN A PASSION POINT
OF MINE SINCE I HAVE BEEN THE
CHAIR.
WE HAVE TO START INVESTING
LONG-TERM IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HABITUALLY BEEN DEMOCRATS
AND SAY THAT DEMOCRATS TAKE YOUR
VOTE FOR GRANTED.
HERE WE ARE IS THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY STARTING A CONVERSATION IN
BEING PART OF YOUR COMMUNITY AND
INTERACTING.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS HUGE GROWTH
WITH THE LATINO COMMUNITY IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY IN THE ASIAN
COMMUNITY BECAUSE FINALLY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS SHOWING UP.
WE ARE OPENING THESE OFFICES
THIS YEAR AHEAD OF THE 2022
ELECTION.
>> Dana: ARE YOU STARTING TO
SEE RESULTS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NOT JUST WITH VOTERS, BUT WITH A
DIVERSITY OF THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
LOOK AT THE FIRST TWO
KOREAN-AMERICAN WOMEN TO SERVE
IN CONGRESS.
THEY ARE REPUBLICAN.
PEOPLE COMING FROM MIAMI.
THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAD TWO
SPANISH ONLY SPEAKING OFFICES IN
BROWARD COUNTY IN MIAMI.
THIS IS A CORRELATION OF AN
OUTREACH EFFORT FROM THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT HAS BEEN
LONG TERM AND SUSTAINED FOR FIVE
YEARS NOW.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RAISING IS A LIMES
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THEY HAVE
A PROBLEM?
>> THEY DO.
YOU LOOK AT TEXAS JUST THIS PAST
WEEK.
McALLEN AND FORT WORTH.
HISPANIC AREAS THAT WENT
REPUBLICAN IN THEIR MAYOR RACES.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AS THEY
ARE SAYING WE LOVE THIS COUNTRY
AND WE CAME HERE TO ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
WE WORKED HARD AND WE DID IT.
DID NOT TELL US THIS IS RACIST.
IT IS THE GREATEST NATION ON
EARTH.
THAT IS WHAT I HEAR ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AS I SPEAK TO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
TRADITIONALLY BEEN REPUBLICAN
BUT ARE NOW SHIFTING TO OUR
PARTY.
WE DIDN’T BRAND THE DEMOCRATS
RADICALS.
THEY DID NOT ALL IN THEMSELVES.
>> Dana: IS A BORDER ISSUE AND
IMMIGRATION IN PARTICULAR
SOMETHING YOU ARE STARTING TO
SEE CHANGE IN TEXAS AND
ELSEWHERE?
>> YES.
IN 2020, THE CAMPAIGN SLEPT FOR
REPUBLICANS FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE 1920s BECAUSE THEY
WANT SUSTAINED IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
THEY ARE WATCHING KAMALA HARRIS
AND JOE BIDEN TURNED THEIR BACK
ON THE BORDER.
THEY WANT TO SEE A POLICY PUT
FORWARD IN A BIPARTISAN WAY AND
ACTUALLY WORK TO SOLVE OUR
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THEY KNOW DRUGS ARE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY ALSO KNOW THIS IS NOT
HUMANE.
KIDS ARE BEING DROPPED OFF BY
THEMSELVES AND FAMILIES ARE
TAKING THIS TREACHEROUS JOURNEY
UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
CARTELS.
NOTHING THAT THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING TO THESE
FAMILIES IS HUMANE.
>> Dana: WE WILL KEEP IN TOUCH